>> Tucker: IT'S FRIDAY.
NATURALLY THINGS ARE BLOWING
UP.
ESPECIALLY DAN BONGINO'S NEWS
EXPLOSION.
OUR FORMER -- FAVORITE FORMER
SECRET SERVICE AGENT AND NEW
YORK CITY COP HERE TO RANK THE
TOP THREE STORIES OF THE PAST
WEEK.
HEY, DAN.
>> HEY!
TUCKER, HOW ARE YOU?
I'M HAPPY TO BE HERE.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE SEGMENT OF
THE WEEK.
GET TO IT.
THE MOST EXPLOSIVE STORY OF
THE WEEK.
NUMERO TRES, NUMBER THREE.
JOE BIDEN DISCOVERS THE MONEY
FAIRY AND WANTS TO GIVE
HEALTHCARE TO PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
HAVE YOU HEARD THIS?
THIS IS FASCINATING.
SO WHEN YOU FACTOR OUT THE
UNITED STATES, THE WORLD HAS 7
BILLION PEOPLE.
OF COURSE, THERE IS NO RATE
LIMITING FACTOR PROVIDING
HEALTHCARE FOR EVERYONE.
HOW WE AFFORD THAT, I HAVE NO
IDEA.
BUT JOE BIDEN WILL FIGURE IT
OUT IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
MONEY FAIRY.
HE'S GOT THIS.
>> I CAN'T WAIT TO SEE THE
MONEY FAIRY.
>> CRAZY THAT HAPPENED.
EXPLOSIVE STORY NUMBER TWO OF
THE WEEK.
CHINA GETS A TASTE OF ITS OWN
MEDICINE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAMMERS CHINA
BACK WITH 25% TARIFFS.
I'M A FREE TRADER.
I KNOW YOU PROBABLY ARE, TOO.
BUT CHINA IS NOT TRADING
FAIRLY.
WE TOLD THEM WHEN THEY JUMPED JI
WE TOLD THEM WHEN THEY JUMPED JE
WE TOLD THEM WHEN THEY JUMPED JD
THEY WOULD HANDLE THEMSELVES
FOR FREELY BUT IT HASN'T
HAPPENED.
GOOD FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR
FIGHTING BACK.
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STORY.
>> Tucker: ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS BIG.
THE GOLD MEDAL OF STORIES THIS
WEEK.
I HAVE TO SPEND A LITTLE TIME
ON THIS.
THIS IS CRITICAL.
JERRY NADLER, JERRY NADLER
COMPETING WITH ADAM SCHIFF TO
BE THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IN
CONGRESS, NADLER FILING
CONTEMPT CHARGES AGAINST
ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL BARR FOR
NOT PRODUCING A REPORT,
TUCKER, THAT YOU AND I CAN GET
ON OUR iPHONES RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN GO -- DID YOU KNOW
THIS?
THIS MAY BE BREAKING NEWS.
YOU'RE LAUGHING BUT YOU CAN GO
TO AMAZON RIGHT NOW, OR BARNES
& NOBLE OR WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO DO AND PICK UP A COPY OF
THE MUELLER REPORT THAT JERRY
NADLER WANTS TO FILE CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST BILL BARR FOR
NOT PRODUCING.
ARE WE LIVING ON PEAK STUPID?
ARE YOU AND I CRAZY OR WE ARE
PEAK STUPID?
THIS ONE PIECE OF THE REACTION
THAT THEY WANT THAT BILL BARR
CANNOT PRODUCE BECAUSE IT'S
CONGRESS' OWN LAW.
DO YOU FIND IT CONFUSING?
YOU CAN BUY THE MUELLER
REPORT.
THE REDACTIONS HE WANTS HE
CAN'T GET BECAUSE CONGRESS
CREATED THIS LAW OF THE
FEDERAL RULE 16.
AGAIN, WE ARE LIVING IN THE
DUMBEST OF TIMES.
I'M HAVE TO DO THAT.
IT REMINDS ME OF BILLY
MADISON.
DO YOU REMEMBER THE SCENE
WE'RE ALL DUMBER FOR HAVING
HEARD THAT NOW.
>> Tucker: AND DEGRADING,
TOO.
HATING THIS MUCH DIMINISHES
PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE BEEN DIMINISHED.
I THINK NADLER WAS NEVER THAT
IMPRESSIVE BUT WE WASN'T A
FULL ON BUFFOON AS HE TODAY.
DAN BONGINO.
>> DOESN'T IT MAKE YOU FEEL
BAD THE PEOPLE ARE IN POWER?
IT'S PATHETIC.
>> Tucker: I WOULDN'T WANT
THEM TO HAVE MORE POWER.
THAT WOULD MAKE ME VERY
NERVOUS.